welcome to analog I'm Lisa Foyle's your
red-haired host and speaking of redheads
there is nothing I love more than a
ginger protagonist especially one with a
giant mega sword child of light the
platforming RPG for all modern consoles
PC and recently released for Vita stars
Aurora young princess who wakes up in a
mysterious and somber fairytale world if
you missed the whimsy and need another
adventure in a similar style then here
are three games like child of light I
told you I love redheads and transistor
and action RPG for ps4 and PC stars a
nightclub singer appropriately named red
child of light and transistor begin in a
similar fashion you're in a strange
world and the game tells you very little
red removes a giant sword from a dead
man's body this is the transistor both
red and the dead man's voices are
trapped inside this weapon and the man
acts as a narrator the narrating voice
guides you and helps piece together the
story's mystery as red tries to uncover
what has happened to her world cloud
bank and defeat the evil force known as
the process while child of light is
traditional turn-based combat transistor
puts a spin on it when an enemy
approaches you can pause time draw your
intended attacks then red carries them
out in sequence it's a mixture of
turn-based and real-time transistor
differs from child of light in the sense
that it's a sci-fi technological city
instead of a fairy tale yes they both
share the same color palette and
hand-drawn art they are both games with
soul a touch of magic and a red head did
I mention that
here's another title by supergiant games
but while transistor is only for ps4 and
PC Bastion is available to 360 owners
and takes place in the sky you as the
kid awaken after the calamity a
catastrophic event that has fractured
your world into many pieces suspended in
the air you set off for the bastion a
safe haven for survivors but how you get
there isn't average platforming as you
travel from floating piece to floating
piece the world forms under your feet
this instant level creation drives you
forward and directs your progress but be
careful because you're now in danger of
plummeting off the end
don't worry anytime you fall or do
something stupid the griz-lee voice
narrator is there to comment and make
fun
good news is the emergency defenses
still work bad news is the Ament for the
kid this bit of humor puts a lighter
spin on an otherwise dark tale like
child of light this game looks like a
bright storybook but it gets more and
more somber as you progress if child of
lights battles were a bit slow for you
then Bastion speeds things up with
normal action combat plus varied weapons
and the ability to upgrade them you must
move quick be aware of your space and
know which quirky enemy to strike first
my favorite moments as Aurora were the
times I got to fly through the air
forgetting my troubles and just floating
if you feel the same way then swap
soaring for swimming in the indie game
aquaria in line with the other
suggestions aquaria boast gorgeous
hand-drawn environments and an
enchanting musical score
you play as Nyjah a woman with Fishlake
features who has lost her memory you
embark on a journey to learn about your
past and your home instead of being
guided you're in an open world
underwater able to swim where you please
you get rewarded for exploring puzzles
range from simple to holy crap I need a
walkthrough combat can be tough but
you'll get a little help along the way
in child of light igniculus is Aurora's
glowing companion who helps with healing
and blinds enemies similarly aquaria has
pets that you acquire after defeating
bosses and they provide combat
assistance for example piranha bytes and
devours Dumbo creates a glow of light
and blasters got firepower aquaria is a
game for patient players who love
getting lost in a mysterious haunting
story each of these games requires focus
creativity in combat and have an art
style that is to die for
but aquaria is the only game with happy
dolphins and sea otters if you're into
that leave a comment with games you
think are like child of light plus send
me a tweet at Lisa Foyle's I'll see you
next week on analog